اهلا بكم الى ساعه اخباريه مفصله من
العربيه نبدا باهم عناوينها
اشتباكات وانفجارات في الخرطوم تخرق
الهدنه والجيش السوداني يعلن احباطه هجوم
للدعم السريع شمال كردفان
في دارفور تحذير من حملات تسريح للشباب
داخل الاحياء تحت غطاء الحمايه الشخصيه
في اخبارنا ايضا
بعد هجوم الكرملين روسيا تصعد من قصفها
على اوكرانيا وتحذر من مواجهه عسكريه
وشيكه مع واشنطن
السلطات البريطانيه تستكمل استعدادها لحفل
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث المقرر غدا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله فهدى مراسل العربيه بسماع دوي
في جارات ضخمه في الخرطوم وبتحليق
للطائرات في سماء العاصمه اليوم ياتي هذا
بعد ان اكد الدعم السريع في بيان قبوله
تمديد الهدنه لسنتين وسبعين ساعه بوساطه
سعوديه امريكيه والالتزام بوقف اطلاق
النار كما اعلن الدعم السريع ترحيبه
بالمبادرات المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه
لوقف اطلاق النار بهدف فتح ممرات انسانيه
وتسيل حركه المواطنين
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه في السودان اعلن
الجيش السوداني في بيان له عن احباط هجوم
لقوات الدعم السريع على مدينه الاوبيض
شمال كردفان حيث توجد ثاني اكبر حامي
عسكريه في البلاد وفرض سيطره كامله على
المدينه اوضح البيان ان قوه من الجيش
اشتبكت مع الدعم السريع وكبدتهم خسائر
كبيره في الارواح مع تدمير ثلاث مركبات
اضاف الجيش السوداني ان دعم سريع شانه
هجوما على معسكر تدريب في جبل كوردوفان
اسفر عن مقتل 15 عسكريا بينهم اثنان من
الضباط كما لاحقت مجموعات من الهجانه
التابعه للجيش عناصر الدعم السريع في عدد
من شوارع وازقه المدينه وفق البيان
من جانبه جدد السفير دفعل الحاج مبعوث
رئيس مجلس سياده الانتقالي التاكيد على ان
الهدنه الحاليه في السودان انسانيه مؤكدا
عدم وجود اتفاق او مفاوضات مع قوات الدعم
السريع
تحدثنا عن اهميه الهدنه ذكرت لهم ان السيد
الرئيس قد وافق على هدنه لاسباب انسانيه
اكثر من مره
واخر مره عندما
تقدمت المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمبادره
وافق عليها السيد الرئيس
حتى انه اعطى موافقه لفتره اطول مما كانت
عليه فترات الهدنه السابقه
اكد مبعوثه عبد الفتاح البرهان من اديسا
ابابا دفع الله حاج ان الوضع على الارض في
السودان مستقر وان الجيش سيطر على مواقع
استولى عليها الدعم السريع واضاف دفع الله
الحاج ان قوات الجيش تواجه تمردا وليس
طرفا يمكن التفاوض مع مضيفا ان الحرص على
سلامه مدنيين في السودان كان اولويه اجلت
حسم المعركه ضد قوات الدعم السريع مبعوث
البرهان اضاف ايضا في حديثه ان الهدنه
تقبل لاغراض انسانيه فقط وان الوساطات مع
قوات الدعم السريع مرفوضه
مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه النزار كيف هي
الاوضاع في بورت سودان فيما يتعلق بعمليات
الاجلاء لا زالت مستمره الكثافه كذلك ايضا
كيف يمكن الحديث عنها
نبدا بعناوين واضحه وملخصه لمالات الاوضاع
خلال الايام الماضيه هذا هو اليوم الخامس
لحاله الطوارئ التي فرضت هنا في ولايه
البحر الاحمر حاله من الاستقرار الامني
والخدمي والتنموي والصحي والاجتماعي تسود
هذه المنطقه من شرق السودان في محور اخر
ايضا وعنوان رئيس يوم الامس بدا الجسر
الجوي الكويتي الذي سينتقل من دوله الكويت
الى مدينه بورسودان خلال الايام الاربع
المقبله ليحمل نحو 75 طن من المواد
الاغاثيه والايوائيه والطبيه للاسهام في
دفع العمليات الانسانيه هنا في شرق
السودان وفي عدد من الولايات المتاثره
جراء الاشتباكات واعمال العنف التي حدثت
خلال الايام الماضيه فيما فيما يتعلق
بمسار الاجلاء عبر ميناء بورسودان الذي
نتحدث منه الان وعبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
المطار الان استقبل نحو 90 رحله جويه خلال
الايام الماضيه هذه الطائرات التي حطت في
مطار بورسودان الدولي اقلت اكثر من 13 الف
من رعايه الدول وممثلي البعثات ومن حمله
الجوازات الاجنبيه اما هنا في ميناء
بورسودان حيث تتابعون الان هذه الصور لهذا
الميناء هذا الميناء استقبل مساء الامس
احدى السفن الاسبانيه التي ستجلي بعد قليل
عشرات من رعايه الاتحاد الاوروبي الذين
وصلوا الى مدينه بورسودان خلال الساعات
الماضيه عمليات الاجلاء حتى هذا اليوم
فاقت الثلاثين رحله بحريه لسفن بحريه
وحربيه ووصلت ايضا خلال الايام الماضيه
الى مدينه بورسودان في سياق عمليه الاجلاء
المتواصله منذ الحادي والعشرين من الشهر
الماضي عبر ميناء بورسودان وحتى هذا اليوم
كما ذكرنا تستمر هذه العمليات بتنسيق
مباشر مع اللجنه المعنيه هنا بعمليه
الايلاء وبتنسيق مباشر قياده الجيش في
المنطقه العسكريه وبين هيئه الموانئ وبين
الشرطه السودانيه الذين يعملون في تنسيق
لاستكمال هذه العمليه عمليات الاجلاء نضيف
ايضا في احدى المعطيات بان عددا ايضا من
طالبي الاجلاء وصلوا ايضا خلال الساعات
الماضيه الى مدينه هم الان في عدد من
الفنادق ينتظرون ايضا استكمال اجراءات
سفرهم وبعدها مباشره ينسقون مع سفاراتهم
ويغادرون السودان طيب بالنسبه لجدول اليوم
فيما يخص عمليات الاجراء التي ستنطلق من
بورتسودان اتحدث عن الميناء اتحدث عن
المطار وبالنسبه ايضا
كذلك السفن التي من المتوقع ان تصل الى
الميناء اليوم
لاجلال لعمليات الاجلال اتمام ايضا نقل
مواطني بعض الدول الموجودين في بورتسودان
هل بالمعلومات حولها نساء
نعم يعني الميناء الرئيسي في بورسودان
تاتي التحديثات دائما منتصف النهار بان
سفينه بحريه في طريقها الى الميناء المؤكد
بان السفينه الاسبانيه ستغادر خلال
الساعات المقبله بعد ان تستكمل اجراءات
النقل واجراءات اجلاء كل من يرغب من رعايه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وربما ايضا جنسيات اخرى
وجنسيات مختلفه قد تغادر خلال الساعات
المقبله نتوقع ايضا بحكم التنسيق وبحكم
الوصول المستمر لاكبر اسطول ولاكبر سفن
بحريه وصلت الى بورسودان وهي السفن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه التابعه للبحريه
الملكيه السعوديه نتوقع ايضا في غضون
الساعات المقبله ان تصل احدى السفن او
القطعه البحريه الى ميناء بورسودان في
اطار ايضا التنسيق المشترك بين السودان
وبين مختلف البعثات وبين سفاره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه فيما يلي المطار نتوقع
ايضا خلال هذا بحكم التواصل المستمر مع
اداره المطار بان هنالك يوميا ما بين 6
الى 8 رحلات يوميا تغادر مطار بورسودان
الدولي الحركه فيه مستمره تبدا منذ
الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم وتستمر حتى
منتصف الليل في طائرات
تاخذ الاذن من اداره المطار من السلطات
الامنيه هنا في الشرق السودان وبعدها
مباشره تصل الى المطار وتبدا في اجلاء
رعايه الدول الاجنبيه او حمله الجوازات او
ما يرغبون في مغادره السودان كاميرا
المتوقع ان كان هناك من تقديرات حسب
المعلومات نزار ان تقل هذه السفينه
الاسبانيه التي ستجلي مواطني المواطنين
الاسبان اولا وكذلك من يرغب بالخروج من
بورد سودان من مواطني دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي
دائما هذه السفن تقيل بين 150 الى مئتين
كحد متوسط وهنالك بالتاكيد السفن كبرى
وناقلات كبرى بحريه حربيه هي من هي من تقل
اعداد كبيره اكثر من 500 اكثر من 400 لكن
العدد المتوسط الان للسفن والقطع التي
تاتي من اوروبا تاتي من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي تاتي من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه دائما ما تقيل ما بين 100 الى
150 الى 200 الاعداد متزايده هنالك جدول
يصدر منتصف الاسبوع تقوم اللجنه المختصه
بعمليه الاله بتوضيح عدد الذين غادروا
بالرقم وتوضح ايضا عدد السفن والقطعه
البحريه التي وصلت خلال الايام الماضيه من
اي دوله من اي وجهه من بورسودان الى اين
تمضي الى اين تستقر كل هذه الارقام كل هذه
الحيثيات كل هذه المعلومات ستصدر عبر جدول
يسلم الى الجهات وبعدها ينشر ليوضح حقيقه
ما تم من عمليات اجلاء سواء كان في مطار
بورسودان الدولي او داخل ميناء بورسودان
هنا حيث نتحدث اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل التي وفيتنا بها
من بورتسودان مراسل العربيه نزار
حضر عدد من المتطوعين والناشطين بجنوب
دارفور اثناء تنفيذ حمله صحيه بمستشفى
نيالا التعليمي من عمليه تسليح الشباب
داخل الاحياء باقليم دارفور بحجه حمايته
معتبرين ان الخطوه يمكنها ان تؤدي الى
انزلاق البلاد في شبح الحرب الاهليه في ظل
انعدام الامن بدرفور
يعتبر سوق التوابل بمدينه نيالا غربيه
السودان احد اكبر الاسواق في غرب افريقيا
واعرقها هنا في اقليم دارفور القذائف التي
سقطت عليه جراء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في احداثي الخامس عشر من
ابريل حولت السوق الى رماد الخسائر كبيره
بحسب حديثي لجنه الحصر احنا الان في سوق
الشطه يعني الخسائر بتاعتنا تفوق
التريليون دي حجم البضائع اضافه لذلك
المباني
والممتلكات الخاصه
والمستندات وكل التفاصيل انتهت الان تحت
الركام يعني
لا نقول الا ما يرضي الله انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون
من الدمار ويحاول عيسى موسى اصلاح المكان
وتلبيته احتياجات زبائن رغم من المعاناه
والتعب ولابد لنا من انه نقدح ونعمل
لاعاده تاهيل السوق
ولكي نكسب ونعيش وناهل نفسنا ونرمي ما
تدمر من جراء الحرب في مجتمع يكابده
للخروج من ازمات عديده تاتي هذه الحرب هنا
في اقليم دارفور لتضيف عبئا اخر على حياته
ونذكر مشاهدينا بالاخبار العاجله حيث يسود
الهدوء الحذر في العاصمه الخرطوم بعد ذوي
انفجارات
سمع طبعا صوتها في العاصمه الخرطوم اصوات
ايضا حتى كذلك لاطلاق الرصاص في
الخرطوم لكن الحديث الان عن حاله من
الهدوء ايضا تسود العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم نتابع هذا الفيديو ثم نعود بعد
ذلك الى الزميل عمار ابو شيبه
[موسيقى]
يحلق في سماء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
كما ذكر مراسل العربيه قبل قليل
لتحليق طائرات في سمام العاصمه الخرطوم
وذلك كما ذكرنا بعد ان تم سماع اصوات
انفجار الضخمه في العاصمه الخرطوم وساده
بعدها الهدوء النسبي
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه عمر مرحبا بك معي هلا الهدوء هو
السائد في العاصمه الخرطوم خلال هذه
الساعه ام تغيرت الامور حتى الان عمار
نعم يعني هذا الهدوء الان يعم المنطقه
الهدوء النسبي والحذر في عدد من المناطق
التي جرت فيها اشتباكات وسميع لدويه
الانفجارات في صباح اليوم كان هنالك تحليق
لطائرات الاستطلاع قبل قليل ولكن لم ينفذ
الطيران الحربي او المقاتلات الحربيه
طلعات جويه في اللحظات الماضيه هدوءا
نسبيا نشاهده في المنطقه وعدد من المصادر
تتحدث مصادر ميدانيه تتحدث عن عمليه تحشيد
تجري في منطقه السوق العربي وفي المناطق
المتاخمه للقصر الرئاسي ربما تدور معارك
في الساعات القادمه في تلك المنطقه
باعتبار ان الجيش حاول في اكثر من مره على
على غرار الايام الماضيه للدخول لهذه
المنطقه التي تتحصن فيها قوات الدعم
السريع والتي تحدثت في اكثر من بيان قوات
الدعم السريع بانها استطاعت سد كثير من
الهجمات ومحاوله اختراق في تلك المنطقه
الوضع الوضع الان في هذه المنطقه يبدو
هادئا نسبيا حركه المواطنين في عدد من
الشوارع نلاحظ ان الحركه بدات ترجع
تدريجيا للمواصلات في مناطق الشرق العاصمه
الخرطوم والمنطقه الجنوبيه الخاصه
والمتاخمه بالسوق المركزي والتي جرت فيها
اشتباكات في الايام الاولى ولكن الان
هنالك هدوءا حذرا ونسبيا في المنطقه طيب
اسال كذلك عن عمليات النزوح من العاصمه
الخرطوم الى ولايات قريبه من
العاصمه كيف يمكن الحديث عنه ايضا تقييم
الامور كيف تجري عمار كذلك
ربما اقلت عمليات الخروج من المناطق في
دائره الاشتباك والمناطق التي كانت تتاخم
بشكل كبير المحيط العام لقياده الجيش او
مطار الخرطوم او حتى القصر الرئاسي او حتى
الاحياء القديمه من مدينه ام درمان ومدينه
بحري ومنطقه الخرطوم شرق قلت عمليات
الخروج باعتبار ان كثيرين خرجوا في الايام
الاولى وذهبوا الى مناطق اكثر امنا في
ولايه الجزيره او الولايات الشماليه او
حتى منطقه شمال ام درمان وهذه العمليات
الكثيره جدا التي كانت لعمليات الخروج
لمناطق اكثر امنا ساهمت فيها كثير جدا من
حركه السيارات وربما الحافلات السفريه لا
نلاحظ هذه الحركه الان مثلما كانت في
الايام الاولى باعتبار اننا دخلنا في
الاسبوع الرابع على مشارف هذا الاسبوع من
عمر هذه الحرب وكثيرين استطاعوا ان يعبروا
الى تلك المناطق
وتامنوا فيها بشكل واضح ولهم فيها معارف
واقارب واستطاعوا من خلالها ان يامنوا على
انفسهم في تلك المناطق الان تتحدث كثير
جدا من المنظمات على الارض الواقع بان
عمليات الخروج التي تمت تقارب لارقام
واعداد كبيره جدا تتحدث المنظمات غير
الرسميه عن خروج ما لا يقل عن ثمانين الف
في هذه المناطق التي كانت تتواجد فيها
كثير من المجمعات السكنيه وكثير جدا من
الاهالي في هذه المناطق وكثير ايضا من
الاهالي والمعارف الذين تحدثنا اليهم
اشاروا الى فقدانهم لكثير جدا من
المقتنيات والسيارات ولا يستطيعون حتى
عمليه التبليغ عن الاشياء التي فقدوها
وهنالك ايضا مبادرات ومناشدات تنتشر بشكل
واضح على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لكثير
من المفقودين الذين خرجوا ولم يعودوا حتى
الان نلاحظ ذلك وبشده في مناطق كثيره جدا
خاصه المناطق ذات الاشتباكات العنيفه التي
تدور ما بين فتره واخرى
وهذا يبدو واضحا ايضا كذلك من خلال ازدياد
القتلى وازدياد الجرحى والذي يعلن في كل
ساعه عن زياده جديده في عدد القتلى او عدد
الجرحى اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم الصحه
في اعمار ابو شيبه على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
على صعيد الوضع الانساني وعمليات الاجلاء
من السودان وصل عشرات الالاف من الوافدين
السودانيين الى ميناء قسطل وميناء ارجيل
في مصر بحثا عن الحمايه الدوليه وفقا
للارقام التي تلقتها المفوضيه من الصفحه
الرسميه لوزاره الخارجيه المصريه فقد بلغ
عدد الاشخاص الذين عبروا الحدود المصريه
من السودان او الحدود المصريه من السودان
الى اكثر من 50 الف شخص حتى الثالث من
مايو بينهم 47 الف سوداني وثلاثه الاف
وخمسمائه شخص من جنسيات اخرى
[موسيقى]
رحله طويله ومرعبه الى بر الامان اثقلت
كاهل هؤلاء الطلاب الافارقه وزادت
معاناتهم اخر ليله هانئه في المكان الذي
احتضنت طموحاتهم انزلت الرعب في نفوسهم
وتركت مئات النيجيريين في العراء لمده
سبعه ايام مؤلمه
حقائب مكدسه لملم هؤلاء فيها ما طالت
ايديهم اولا فلم تعد الذكريات تهم انما
الخلاص اهم
دول غنيه مثل الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ارسل الطائرات لاجلاء رعاياها بينما كافح
العديد من الافارقه لايجاد مخرج من
العاصمه التي مزقتها الحرب
تكدس الالاف في الحافلات والشاحنات في
الرحله الممتده ل 800 كيلومتر برا من
الخرطوم الى بورت سودان في ولايه البحر
الاحمر للصعود على متن السفينه بينما توجه
اخرون صوب الشمال لمسافه تبلغ الف كيلو
متر الى حدود مصر ليجدوا انفسهم عالقين في
صفوف انتظار تستمر اياما للسماح لهم
بالعبور
لكن مع تزايد الاعداد وشح الوقود قفزت
اسعار التنقل الى مئات الدولارات لتكون
بعيدا عن متناول الكثيرين ومن بينهم
الطلبه
هي من هنا وكان المكان غير الصحي ابدا لقد
كان موقفا صعبا للغايه
الحكومه النيجيريه حاولت استئجار 250
حافله لاجلاء حوالي
5500 من مواطنيها لكنها لم تستطع توفير
الا 40 حافله
رحله على الجمر عاشها هؤلاء بالشقاء
والعناء لا يبرد وهاجها سوى حضن الوطن ولو
لم يكن حاله افضل
هذا ووصلت السفينه السعوديه امانه الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده
على متنها اكثر من
1760 شخصا من 33 جنسيه مختلفه تم اجلائهم
من السودان وفي وقت سابق وصلت سفينه
امريكيه الى ميناء جده ايضا تحمل على
متنها 222 شخصا
في غضون ذلك قالت المديره التنفيذيه
لليونيسف كاترين راسل ان الوضع في السودان
يتجه نحو كارثه والاطفال يقعون بشكل
متزايد في مرمى النيران مؤكده ان اليونيسف
تلقى التقارير عن مقتل 190 طفلا واصابه
1700 اخرين منذ اندلاع النزاع واضافت راسل
انه يجب ان يتوقف العنف من اجل اطفال
السودان وذلك يشمل وقف جميع الهجمات على
المراكز الصحيه والمدارس والبنيه التحتيه
للمياه والصرف الصحي
كما دعت للسماح باستيراد الامدادات
الانسانيه والتجاريه الاساسيه بما في ذلك
الاغذيه والوقود من دون قيود او عوائق او
انقطاع بغض النظر عما يسيطر على هذه
المناطق واكدت راسل ان اليونس ابتدعو ايضا
الى حل سياسي طويل الامد للازمه
ومن الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد
اسحاق عثمان محمد مرحبا بك معي دعني ابدا
معك طبعا بالاوضاع الانسانيه اولا في
الخرطوم كيف تبدو حتى هذه اللحظه كنت
تحدثني قبل ساعه ونصف من الان عن حافلات
تجلي السكان من مدينه الخرطوم ومحافظه
خرطوم بحري الى ولايه قريبه منها كيف يمكن
تقييم الوضع
[موسيقى]
في هذه المحطه محطه الحافلات التي تقل
هؤلاء الذين يودون مقادره ولايه الخرطوم
في هذه
والذين كما ذكرت قبل قليل بان عددهم في
الزيات وذلك طبعا يعود لطبيعه هذه المنطقه
التي تبدو اكثر امانا وهدوءا المنطقه
منطقه جسر الحلفايه الجديد في الموضوع
باننا قد علمنا قبل قليل من بعض المصادر
بتجدد هذه الاشتبا في منطقه كافوري
وكذلك اشتعال بعض الاشتباكات ايضا
بالاسلحه الخفيفه في منطقه شرق النيله
التي بالتحديد في محيط مستشفى شرق هذا
في المستشفى للمعلوميه نايف تسيطر عليه
قوات الدعم السريع وتنتشر في محيطه بكثافه
علمنا قبل قليل بان اشتباكات دائره ربما
هذه خطه جديده كما علمنا يحاول الجيش
افراق هذه المستشفيات والدور الصحيه من
هذه السيطره وهذه الهيمنه التي تتم عليها
من قبل الهيمنه او السيطره على هذه
المستشفيات تعني انها اصبحت تكنه عسكريه
لم تعد مرفقا صحيا محمد
لذلك يحاول الجيش تحرير هذه المستشفيات
بمقبضه الدعم السريع الذي قام بتحويلها
الى
اخره
وهذه المستشفىات تقع في وسط الاحياء
السكنيه لما يشكل خطوره واسعه على
القادمه
جديده في تحول مسار هذه المعارك كيف يعني
سيكون هناك تحول في سير هذه المعارك هل
هناك من مؤشرات او مقدمات تدلل على ان
هناك تغير
يكتنف المرحله القادمه عسكريا ميدانيا
نتحدث
نعم نايف لان الحديث دعمنا الذي يردد من
قبل الجيش
بانهم ربما في الساعات او الايام يتحدثون
هكذا عن بعض
الضربات التي اطلقوا عليها باسم الضربات
الحاسمه او المعارك الحاسبه لان
هذا الظهور الكثيف للطيران الذي اراه
يزداد في كل بره هذه العدديه من الطلعات
الجويه تزداد هذا مؤشر واضح بان الجيش
ربما يرتب في الساعات القادمه
لهجوم كما شاهدناه في اليومين الماضيين
بمحاور مختلفه لان الجيش يتحدث الان عن
هذه المواقع الاستراتيجيه وبدا اهميتها
مساله المستشفيات ونزلت القصر الجمهوري
محيط الاذاعه
التلفزيون اذا
المساطر التي تواصلنا معها تشير بان
الساعات القادمه ربما تشهد معارك حاسمه
وقويه جدا على انفتاح هذه المره احدثك
والان الاحظ ايضا هذه الطائرات التي تجوف
سماع الخرطوم بحري وعددها في زياده ولكن
هل هناك طائرات استطلاع عن طائرات حربيه
يعني هناك اهداف عسكريه محدده على الارض
وتقوم باستهداف هذه الطائرات محمد اي
الاتجاهين تاخذ
هذه طائره من نوع معروف بانها تعمل على
التصوير هذا صوتها قريب الان هذه تصور
المواقع تعقبها مباشره واحده من طائرات
الميج
وعدد كذلك من الاباتشي ايضا شاهدناها قبل
قليل تطوف في
الخرطوم بحري هذه دلاله وعافيه بانه ربما
يتم الترتيب في هذه
الساعات المقبله باننا سنشاهد بحسب بعض
المصادر سنشاهد سيناريوهات جديده وربما
هذه الضربه التي اطلق عليها
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم بحرين
ضميرينا الصحه في محمد اسحاق عثمان
[موسيقى]
والان الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
وملفات اخرى
[موسيقى]
على وقع تصاعد المعارك في بخمت شرق
اوكرانيا
فاجنر من ان قوته ستغادر في العاشر من
مايو الجاري بسبب عدم تامين وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه الذخيره لقواته وقال بيرجوجين ان
استمرار القتالي في المدينه من دون ذخيره
امر لا جدوى بالاضافه الى تكبد خسائر بين
مقاتل فاجنر خلال المواجهات هذا ورفض
الكرملين التعليق على تصريحات قائد فاجنر
بشان الانسحاب من باقمت
اكدت مصادر لوكاله الروسيه ان طيران
الروسيه ضربه على نقطه تمركز مدربين اجانب
للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه الاوكرانيه
حيث حيث تجمع افراد واسلحه واليات عسكريه
اوكرانيه اضاف المصدر للوكاله ان القوات
المسلحه الروسيه دمرت ايضا مجموعتين
استطلاعيتين تابعتين للقوات الاوكرانيه
وافشلت تنفيذ تبادل القوات الاوكرانيه في
اربع وحدات عسكريه في اتجاه محوري
كوبيانسك
بموازاه ذلك قالت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه في بيان الله انها دمرت احدى
طائراتها دون طيار بعد ان بدات في الطيران
خارج نطاق السيطره على منطقه كييف وخلال
رحله جويه مخططه في كير فقدت السيطره على
طائره بدون طيار ما دفع القوات الجويه
لاسقاطها بيار الجيش اضاف فان الطائره
بدون طيار ربما عانت من عطل فني وتاتي هذه
التطورات بعد اعلان موسكو اسقاط مسيرتين
فوق الكرملين يوم امس وهو الهجوم الذي
اتهمت موسكو واشنطن باعطاء الاوامر لكيف
من اجل تنفيذه
[موسيقى]
نجمه الصمود الاوكراني كما وصفت دعمت عمود
المساعدات الغربيه العسكري وصنعت الفارقه
في الحرب لا سيما ان استخدامها جاء من
الطرفين لتحديد مواقع العدو وتوجيه نيران
المدفعيه نحوها
على اعتاب كييف كانت المسيرات الاوكرانيه
اول من اقفل الباب بوجه القوات الروسيه
لتسحب ذيولها خلال ساعات وتتفرق شرقا
وجنوبا فيما الخاصره اي شبه جزيره القرم
التي زرعت الشوكه الروسيه فيها منذ تسع
سنوات تتعرض كل حين لهجمات بالمسيرات
هدفها الاولي قطع امداد المعدات والغذاء
عن موسكو واستهداف اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
جيش الدرون الاوكراني الذي قلل من اضرار
التفوق الروسي حجما وقدره شمل بدايه
مسيرات تجاريه رخيصه الثمن الصينيه الصنع
دي جي اي مافيك حضرت صادراتها بكين لاحقا
على اعتبار انها للاستخدام المدني فقط لكن
مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه شكلت العين
الاساسيه على اوكار الخصومه تحمل كاميرات
استطلاعيه ويمكن تسليحها بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر واستخدمت بالهجوم الذي اغرق سفينه
موسكفا الروسيه في ابريل 2022 لكن هذه
المسيرات يعيبها حجمها الكبير وببطء
حركتها وسهوله اسقاطها مقارنه بكمكاز
الانتحاريه فالعصافير القاتله او الذخيره
المتسكعه تتميز بقدرتها على التحليق في
منطقه الهدف المحدد مسبقا وتضرب عند
التعرف الى العدو تطلق من مسافات بعيده
ويصعب اكتشافها لصغر حجمها اهميه هذا
السلاح ادركته موسكو سريعا فاندفعت الى
ايران لشراء مسيرات انتحاريه عمياء بدقه
ضعيفه استخدمتها لاول مره في خركيف ثم
كييف واداس
غير ان هذه المسيرات لم ترقى لتوقعات
الروس واخفقت كثيرا وفق واشنطن
اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسي الهجوم على
الكلمه كان عملا اعدائيا وروسيا سترد
بخطوات ملموسه واعتبر لابروف ان كييف لن
تحاول مهاجمه الكريم من دون اخطار
لسادتها في الغرب حسب وصفه كشف وزير
خارجيه روسي ايضا ان موسكو مستعده للتحدث
مع الغرب وهذا سيحدث عاجلا ام اجلا
من جانبه حضر نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيس
من ان العلاقات الروسيه الامريكيه تقترب
من حافه المواجهه المسلحه مشيرا الى ان
موسكو تحول الحفاظ على العلاقات مع واشنطن
لمنع سقوطها في هويه النزاع المسلح
واضافكو فان روسيا مستعده لاستخدام كل
الوسائل الممكنه لضمان عدم السماح لاي جهه
بالتعدي على امن روسيا وسلامه رئيسها
وقيادتها السياسيه
هذا وقلص التروسيه احتفالات يوم النصر
لهذا العام اذ ارجعت موسكو قرارها لاسباب
امنيه وهجمات لجهات مواليه لاوكرانيا
وكانت الفخامه وعروض القوه العسكريه
السمات المميزه المعتاده ليوم النصر الذي
يصادف ذكرا انتصار الاتحاد السوفيتي على
المانيا النازيه في التاسع من مايو سنه
[موسيقى]
ومن موسكو يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد ومن كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بكما معي في هذه الساعه وابدا
معك عبد الجواد من اخر تصريحات الكرملين
التي رفض فيها التعليق على حديث قائد قوات
باجنر والكثير من التصريحات ايضا التي
خرجت من كيف يمكن ان تجميلها لنا
مرحبا نايف لك ولي حذيفه نعم صحيح ما تقول
الكرملين رفض التصريح عما تحدث به قائد
مجموعه ومؤسس
حول الخروج من مدينه باتموت في العاشر من
الشهر الجاري لكن المتحدث الرسمي باسم
القرار الذي سيقوم به
وان القوات الروسيه ووزاره الدفاع تحضر
الان الاستلام كافه المراكز من قواتنا
الرابع هي تصريحات مثيره للجدل خرج بها
الامس متهما وزاره الدفاع والاركان العامه
الروسيه بعدم تزويد هذه القوات الخاصه
بالشركه العسكريه التابعه
ما يلزمها من معدات تحدث عن انه من بدايه
شهر مايو لم يتلقى اي نوع من الذخيره من
القوات الروسيه على عكس ما كان عليه تطرق
الى ان من الذخيره كانت تنقص قوات الى
مقتل العشرات من هذه القوات خرج اليوم في
شريط الفيديو على خلفيه ومن خلفه طبعا عدد
من المقاتلين الذين سقطوا خلال المعارف في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه في طبعا نايف حتى هذه
اللحظه
الصراع في اوكرانيا لكن محورها يرتكز بشكل
اساسي على ما قامت به اوكرانيا في محاوله
لاستهداف الرئيس الروسي
والمسيرات التي وصلت الى وتم طبعا تعطيلها
هو ضربها
يعني بوسائل الدفاع الجويه في تلك المنطقه
عموما طبعا بما يخص عيد النصر نايف طبعا
تم الاعلان رسميا بان مدينه
العاصمه الجنوبيه والعاصمه العسكريه
الجنوبيه للبلاد وحدها هذه المدينه ستقوم
بتشويد وبالاحتفال بعيد النصر ما عرض
عسكري في المنطقه الجنوبيه وحدها اما
السيناريو في موسكو فهو مستمر كما كان
وكما كان متوقع قد تحدث بان لا تغيير حتى
هذه اللحظه على هذا السيناريو وشوارع
المدينه المحيطه بالساحه الحمراء تغلق كل
يوم كما هي العاده عند المساء لوصول
المعدات الثقيله والقيام بالتدريب على
اداء الارض العسكري طبعا هي قضيه كبيره من
ابرز التصريحات نايف اليوم ما ذكرته على
لسان نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي بان
القنوات موجوده بين موسكو واشنطن خاصه على
المستوى الحديث عن تصريحات الخارجيه
الروسيه لكن قبل ذلك اتحول الى زميلنا
ايضا حذيفه عادل من كييف يعني
للسؤال كذلك عن الامدادات الاوكرانيه
الى الشرق الاوكراني خلال هذه الايام
الماضيه ما الذي كان يدور حول هذا الموقف
لاننا نرى موقف مثلا من قائد قوات باج نر
بان هناك تراجع هناك زياده في اعداد
القتلى هناك تقلص ايضا في اعداد الذخيره
التي
يعني يحصل عليها من الجيش الروسي اسال هنا
عن التسريح الاوكراني هناك زادت حدته خلال
الايام الماضيه
تحيه لك نايف ولي الزميل عبد الجواد في
الحقيقه الوضع في الشرق الاوكراني في
الوقت الحالي هنالك عمليه يعني متواصل
للقوات الاوكرانيه الامداد للجيش
الاوكراني في بخموت تحديدا حيث بؤره
الصراع الرئيسيه بين القوات الروسيه
والقوات الاوكرانيه قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه
زار المنطقه بنفسه ووقف على وصول
الامدادات هنالك الطريق الرئيسي شاسا فيار
بخموت وهو الطريق الذي تصل عن طريقه
الامدادات هذا الطريق بشكل جزئي هو تحت
نيران المدفعيه الروسيه حاولت القوات
الروسيه للوصول والسيطره على هذا الطريق
لقطع الامدادات تماما ولكنها فشلت في كل
المحاولات التي حاولتها والقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه قالت انها مطمئنه على وضع هذا
الطريق ولكنه يظل تحت نيران المدفعيه
الروسيه لذلك تعمل الفرق الهندسيه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه في طرق اخرى بديله في
مناطق وعيره لم يكن فيها طرق الان تعمل
على شق هذه الطرق ليكون هنالك طرق امداد
بديله اخرى للوصول الى هذه المواقع للقوات
الاوكرانيه في ضخم طبعا تصر القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه على استمرار الدفاع عن
محمود وان تواصل السيطره على هذه الجفا
وطبعا تعلل ذلك بان هذه الجبهه اذا تم
الانسحاب منها فهذا يفتح الطريق امام
القوات الروسيه للوصول الى كراماتورز الى
مدن رئيسيه في دونيسك كما انها ستزيد من
خط شريط الجبهه الان تركيز القوات الروسيه
في مخمود مارينكا هنالك قصف في اتجاه
الايمان ولكن لا يوجد تقدم بالمشاه في هذا
الاتجاه ولكن اذا اذا انسحبت القوات
الاوكرانيه وصدمت هذه المواقع فانها ستفتح
على نفسها جبهات اخرى في مناطق اخرى طبعا
تصل الامدادات بشكل متواصل الذخيره
والسلاح هنالك الامدادات التي وصلت من
الغرب في الايام الماضيه كذلك
الصراع الكبير الذي وصل الى الخطوط
الحمراء بين موسكو و واشنطن الا ان طبعا
روسيا تتحدث على لسان نائب وزير الخارجيه
يعني وهو الشخص الاول في ملف العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده يتحدث ان العلاقات
الموجوده وقنوات الاتصال مستمره في العمل
خاصه بما يخص يعني ملف الملف السياسي بين
البلدين لكن طبعا تحدث بان روسيا لن تقول
يعني لن تكون مقطوفه الايدي في حال الرضو
ستستخدم كافه الوسائل المتاحه لديها
لحمايه امن البلاد حمايه طبعا رئيس البلاد
والوضع الامني بشكل كلي في الاراضي
الروسيه طبعا راحوا يتحدث عن ان العلاقه
اليوم بين روسيا واوصلت الى يعني مرحلتها
القصوى بما يخص الخطوط الحمراء وصفها هذا
الشيء بحافه الهاويه طبعا هذا التصريح
طبعا بعده خرج الكثير من المحللين
السياسيين في البلاد ويتحدثون عن ضروره
وجود
واستمراريه القنوات بين موسكو وواشنطن
والعمل على هذا الوضع طبعا لا يمكن اخفاء
قلق الجميع من محاوله مواجهه مباشره بين
موسكو واشنطن لكن كما هي حرب بالوكاله
للغرب تجري بينك طيب سريعا حذيفه وباختصار
الوضع في كيف كيف يبدوها الهدوء يعم
المدينه بعد محاوله الهجمات ايضا على
العاصمه اليوم المسيرات
نعم المظهر العام هادئ جدا المواطنين
يتعاملون بشكل طبيعي جدا الحياه تسير بشكل
طبيعي جدا ولكن لا يمكن اخفاء القلق في
نفوس الاوكرانيين تحدثنا اليهم يقولون ان
هنالك قلق طبعا يصورهم حول التاسع من مايو
وما بعد التاسع من مايو من رده فعل موسكو
لهذا ما سموه بالمسرحيه الروسيه والتصعيد
الذي تنوي موسكو ان تقوم به بعد هذا هذه
الدعايه التي اطلقوها حول استهداف كييف
للكريم والامر الذي نفته كيف تماما ايضا
تحدثنا الى بعض المواطنين الذين يقولون
انهم جاهزون للمغادره في حال كان هنالك
تصعيد واسع على النطاق وايضا عدد مقدر من
المواطنين يقولون انه سيبقى في المدينه
ويلجاوا الى الملاجئ اذا ما حدث اشكركما
جزيل الشكر العربيه حذيفه عادل ومن موسكو
براس العربي عبد الجواد الرشد
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه البولنديه
لوكاس جاسين ان بلاده ترى انه بين الضروري
سفيرها لدى روسيا ومن جهتها قالت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا انه بعد ان
استولى سلطات البولنديه على مبنى المدرسه
في السفاره الروسيه في العاصمه البولنديه
وارسو يحق لبلادها قطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع بولندا لكن ذلك سيؤثر بشكل
اساسي على الروس الذين يعيشون في بولندا
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الصيني خلال لقائه
نظيره الروسي سيرجينا بروف على هامش قمه
شنغهاي للتعاون في الهند استعداد بكين
للتعاون مع موسكو وتقديم مساهمه حقيقيه في
تسويه الازمه الاوكرانيه مشيرا الى ان
الصين ستعمل باستمرار على تعزيز مفاوضات
السلام من خلال الاتصالات والتنسيق مع
روسيا كما اكد الوزير الصيني على ان بلاده
وروسيا تحتفظان
باتصالات استراتيجيه وتعزيز للتعاون في
جميع المجالات
ارتفعت مستويات المياه قربى سد نوفا الى
نحو قياسي قد تغمر معها هذا السد الرئيسي
جنوب اوكرانيا نقلا عن وكاله تاس للانباء
الروسيه وحذر رينات كارتشا مستشار المدير
العام لشركه الطاقه النوويه الروسيه ان
هذا الارتفاع القياسي ينذر بتصدع السد
فالمياه ستغمر خط الكهرباء الواصل الى
محطات الضخم في محطه زبروج التي تسيطر
عليها موسكو مضيفا ان هذا سيؤدي الى مشاكل
فنيه لتشغيل المحطه ومخاطر على السلامه
النوويه
[موسيقى]
اعلن جاك سوليف المستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي انه سيزور المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في مطلع الاسبوع لاجراء محادثات
مع قادتها ومناقشه مجالات جديده للتعاون
بين نيودلهي والخليج وكذلك الولايات
المتحده وبقيه المناطق وقال ان خفض
التصعيد والتخلص من الارهاب هو من اولويات
الاداره الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط سولفا
اشار ايضا الى ان الولايات المتحده ستتخذ
الاجراءات الضروريه لمنع ايران من امتلاك
النووي وانها ستسمح لاسرائيل باتخاذ
اللازم حال اقدمت ايران على امتلاك هذا
السلاح وفي سياق متصل قال سلفا انه سيتم
الاعلان عن زياره رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
الى واشنطن في الوقت المناسب اما في الشان
اليمني فقد اعلن سولفا انه تم اتخاذ عدد
من الاجراءات لخط التصعيد هناك
السعوديه في مطلع الاسبوع لاجراء محادثات
مع قادتها اذ تسعى الولايات المتحده الى
التطوير شراكتها مع الرياض كذلك سيزور
ممثلون للهند والامارات السعوديه
لمناقشه مجالات جديده للتعاون بين
النودلهي والخليج وكذلك الولايات المتحده
وبقيه المنطقه وسوف نعلن عن زياره نتنياهو
الى واشنطن في الوقت المناسب
دعوني اذكر بما سبق ان قاله الرئيس بايدن
بنفسه وهو ان التزامنا نحو الشرق الاوسط
افريقيا ثابت لا يهتز لان هذه المنطقه
مهمه جدا من اجل مستقبلنا ومصالحها تتشابك
مع مصالح الولايات المتحده
وشركائنا الاخرين
مبددا بشان القواعد الامريكيه على اراضيها
مؤكدا انها غير مخصصه لشن اي عمل هجومي ضد
اي بلد وخلال لقاء في مركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والدوليه في واشنطن اوضح
ماركوس ان تقديم الفلبين اربع قواعد
عسكريه اضافيه لامريكا لا يعلن انها ستصبح
مواقع لمهاجمه احد مضيفا كذلك ان الولايات
المتحده لم تطلب من الاساس اي مساعده في
حال نشوب حرب بين بكين واشنطن على تايوان
وجهه سلطات البلجيكيه لرجل عراقي تهمه
جرائم قتل بنيه ارهابيه والمشاركه في
اجرطه ارهابيه وجرائم حرب واخرى ضد
الانسانيه الله مكتب المدعي العام فيدرالي
ان المشتبه به يعيش في بلجيكا منذ عام
2015 ويعتقد انه ينتمي لخليه تابعه
للقاعده اشتركت في تفجيرات داخل المنطقه
الخضراء وسط بغداد عامي 2010 قتل خلالها
نحو 376 شخصا وجرح اكثر من
2300 شخص
بعد اختتام الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
زياره استمرت ليومين الى دمشق رحب بيان
مشترك لسوريا وايران بالتطورات السياسيه
الاخيره الايجابيه التي تشهدها المنطقه
خاصه فيما يتعلق بتواصل سوريا البناء مع
الدول العربيه وكذلك الاتفاق الايراني
السعودي حيث اكد البيان ان استئناف
العلاقات بين الرياض والظهران بواسطه
صينيه في مارس الماضي يشكل خطوه مهمه نحو
مزيد من التطورات الايجابيه التي تخدم
استقرار الشرق الاوسط وشدد البيان المشترك
على ضروره التضامن والتماسك بين دول
المنطقه لمواجهه التحديات وتوفير الامن
والهدوء عبر التعاون الاقليمي كما واعرب
الجانبان عن استعدادهما لتطوير العلاقات
التجاريه والاقتصاديه مركزين على سبل
تطويرها
القائم على التعاون فيما بينها فيما يتعلق
باعاده اعمار سوريا
لمده ثمان سنوات
شاركت الجاليه التركيه في المانيا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه واقترع
الالاف لمرشحهم المفضل طوال الايام
الماضيه ويحق لمليون ونصف مليون تركي
يعيشون في المانيا التصويت في الانتخابات
وفي السنوات الماضيه صوتوا
بمعظمهم للرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
قرابه المليون ونصف المليون تركي يعيشون
في المانيا يحق لهم المشاركه بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه وهنا امام القنصليه
التركيه في برلين صفوف طويله من الناخبين
يصطفون للادلاء بصوتهم اصوات الاتراك في
المانيا تذهب بمعظمها بحسب اتجاهات
التصويت في السنوات الماضيه للرئيس الحالي
رجب طيب اردوغان ومع ذلك هذه المره كانت
المعارضه حاضره هنا وان بصوره خجوله معظم
الاتراك في المانيا الذين قدموا بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كانوا مهاجرين عمال
ومكثوا هنا كثيرون منهم ما زالوا يشعرون
بارتباط قوي مع تركيا وكثيرون ايضا خاصه
الكبرى في السن لا يحملون الجنسيه
الالمانيه حتى
اردوغان لديه صوره القائد القوي الذي
يمكنه ان يواجه الغرب والاتراك الذين
يعيشون في المانيا يحبون هذه الصوره وكذلك
هم لا يتاذون من الوضع الاقتصادي في تركيا
الواصلون الجدد الى المانيا من المعارضين
السياسيين مثل حسين دمير واجوزان البيرق
الذين لجاوا بعد الانقلاب الفشل ياملون ان
تحمل الانتخابات في تركيا تغييرا قد ينعكس
عليهم
امل ان تفوز المعارضه فهم وعدوا بانهم
سيحترمون حقوق الانسان ويعيدون العمل
بالقانون وهذا يعني ان كل الاتهامات
الباطله سيتم رفعها وسيصبح القضاء مستقلا
اصوات الاتراك في الخارج تشكل قرابه
الثلاثه نصفهم يصوتون في المانيا ما يعني
ان اصوات الاتراك هنا قد تحدث فرقا في حال
كان الاقبال مرتفعا وهو ما يبدو الحال
عليه هذا العام راغده بهنام العربيه برلين
بتجدد الازمه بين ايطاليا وفرنسا على
خلفيه قضايا الهجره طلب وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي انطونيو تجانب اعتذار فرنسي بعد
تصريحات اعتبرتها روما مهينه طال بعضها
ازمه المهاجرين الذين يصلون بالقوارب كما
الغى تجاني زياره كانت مقرره الى باريس
وذلك بعد اتهام وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني
بانها عاجزه عن حل مشاكل الهجره في بلادها
معتبره تلك التصريحات بانها مهينه وغير
مقبوله
الهوه بين فرنسا وايطاليا تتعمق اكثر
فاكثر باريس تنتقد وروما تستنكر ملف
الهجره يوتر العلاقات بين البلدين
وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيرال دارمانعه
بالعجز عن حل مشاكل الهجره في بلادها
قال ان حكومه اليمين المتطرف التي اختارها
اصدقاء مارينلوبين عاجزه عن ايجاد حلول
لمشاكل الهجره بعد من انتخبت على هذا
الاساس تصريحات اثارت حفيظه الحكومه
الايطاليه على خلفيه ذلك وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي انطونيو جاني الغازا كانت مقرره
الى باريس لن اذهب الى باريس للمشاركه في
الاجتماع الذي كان مقررا اهانات وزير
الداخليه جيرال دارمانان بحق الحكومه
وايطاليا غير مقبوله وز الخارجيه الفرنسيه
حاولت ان تخفف من حده التوتر اذ اكدت ان
فرنسا تريد العمل مع ايطاليا لمواجهه تحدي
الزياده السريعه في تدفق المهاجرين بغض
النظر عن تصريحات وزير الداخليه
التعاون بين البلدين يرتكز في هذا الشان
على المهاجرين من وسط البحر الابيض
المتوسط لكن هذا التعاون ورجوع العلاقات
الى حالها الطبيعي امران قد يحتاجان الى
بعض الوقت حتى تعود المياه الى مجاريها
بلال البجدين العربيه
استكملت السلطات البريطانيه استعدادها في
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث بهذه المناسبه
عدا الحديث عن تكاليف التتويج وسط الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها البلاد تعتبر
تكلفه العائله الملكيه على دفع الضرائب
موضوعا جدليا في بريطانيا ويزداد هذا
الجدل مع اقتراب المراسم والاحتفالات
الملكيه التي تقع على كاهل الموازنه
العامه
[موسيقى]
من عام
1953 توجت الملكه اليزابيث الراحله في حفل
كلف نحو 50 مليون جنيه استرليني واليوم
وبعد 70 عاما تقدر تكلفه تتويج ابنها
ب 100 مليون جنيه بحسب لجنه التنظيم
الفاتوره بما فيها التكاليف الامنيه
والحفل الغنائي الضخم في قلعه وسميسور
تدفعها الحكومه نظرا الى انه حدث دوله
بمعنى ان العبء يقع على الموازنه العامه
ودفع الضرائب في ظل ازمه تكلفه معيشه
يعاني منها الملايين
الملك اخذ الوضع الاقتصادي في الاعتبار
وحاول تقليص الفعاليات جزئيا ولكن اعتقد
ان الاغلبيه تؤيد اقامه حفل تتويج مشرف
لان فعاليات التتويج لا تاتي كل سنه او
حتى كل عقد ويجب ان تلتزم بمستوى عال
واحترام للتقاليد والتاريخ
وفي محاوله لمراعاه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
قلل الملك عدد المدعوين الى نحو 2000 مدعو
مقارنه بثمانيه الاف شخص حضروا تتويج
الملك الراحله المراسم الرسميه داخل كنيسه
واسمنسور ابي ايضا تمت تقليص مدتها من
ثلاث ساعات الى ما بين التسعين دقيقه
وساعتين كما خصص الملك يوما يشجع فيه
المواطنين على التطوع والقيام بالاعمال
الخيريه في مجتمعهم للتجديد على اهتمامه
بمساعده الفقراء والمتضررين
الحكومه بدورها تقول ان الحفل سيجلب
مردودا سياحيا ضخما وسيعطي جرعه نشاطا
للاقتصاد كما يشير المسؤولون الى حقوق
البث لقنوات حول العالم التي من المتوقع
ان تحصل الملايين من الجنيهات للموازنه
الاخر حفل تتويج كان قبل سبعين عاما فهو
فعليا حدث تاريخي واذا نظرنا الى احتفالات
اليوبيل البلاتينيه السنه الماضيه نقدر
انه جلب ملياري جنيه من الانفاق في
المطاعم والفنادق وفي منطقه الويست اند في
لندن المبيعات الاضافيه بلغت 80 مليون
جنيه ولا يزال جدل يدور حول الاجازه
الرسميه من مؤيد يقول انها ستدعم الاقتصاد
بنحو مليار جنيه من خلال الاستهلاك
والسياحه ومن معارض يحذر من تكلفه توقف
العمل قد تتجاوز ملياري جنيه ايا كانت
الفاتوره النهائيه لمراسم التتويج يعد
التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه هو
اقامه احتفال يليق بض خامه هذا الحدث
التاريخي ولكن اخذا في الاعتبار الصعوبه
الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها البريطانيون
كارينا كامل العربيه لندن
وعشيه حفل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث
اظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه الامير ويليام
وزوجته الاميره كيت وهم يحييون الجمهور
البريطاني في حي سوغو الحيوي لندن قربه
قصري باكينغهام
[موسيقى]
قالت السلطات اليابانيه ان زلزالا قوته
سته
وثلاثه من عشره ضرب منطقه
ايشيكا وغرب البلاد وذكرت هيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون اليابانيه انه لم يصدر اي
تحذير من حدوث موجات مد عاتيه تسونامي بعد
الزلزال كما انه لم يتم الابلاغ عن اي
اوضاع غير طبيعيه في محطه شيكا للطاقه
النوويه الواقعه في منطقه ايشيكاوا
هذه الساعه انتهت شكرا لك في المتابعه
زميل ابراهيم بدر يلقاكم في بدايه الساعه
المقبله اليك ابراهيم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات